Fehlt es dir an Selbstvertrauen? Du
möchtest endlich diese eine Frau ansprechen,
deine Selbständigkeit starten oder
einfach mehr zu deiner Meinung stehen,
aber irgendwas hält dich zurück? Vielleicht
hast du auch schon einiges ausprobiert,
um dein Selbstvertrauen zu steigern, aber
nichts klappt so wirklich. Viele unserer
Coaching-Klienten kommen genau mit diesem Problem
zu uns. Einer davon war zum Beispiel Carsten.
Carsten ist Arzt. Seine Herausforderung
war, mehr für sich einzustehen. Ihm hat
der Mut gefehlt höhere Preise zu verlangen und
seine Meinung vor anderen Ärzten zu vertreten.
Natürlich hat er nicht nur im Berufsleben,
sondern auch im Privatleben unter seinem
geringen Selbstwertgefühl gelitten. „Was
wenn ich versage? Was denken andere über
mich? Was wenn ich nicht gut genug bin?“
Diese Gedanken haben ihn ausgebremst. Wenn
auch du mit ähnlichen Gedanken kämpfst, dann
ist dieses Video für dich. Wir schauen uns
jetzt 3 unbequeme, aber mächtige Wege an,
um dein Selbstvertrauen schnell zu steigern.
Die 3 Wege bauen aufeinander auf. Weg
#1 ist die Basis. #2 wird es dir 10x
leichter machen dein Selbstwertgefühl zu
steigern. Weg #3 ist eine konkrete Methode,
die du mit wenigen Minuten am Tag
anwenden kannst. Bist du bereit?
#1: Höre auf rumzuheulen
Menschen, mit einem geringen Selbstwertgefühl
versinken oft in Selbstmitleid. Das Leben ist
hart und unfair. Es bringt dir jedoch
nichts, dich selbst zu bemitleiden.
Heutzutage wird viel davon gesprochen,
dass du dich einfach selbst lieben sollst,
und dann wird alles gut. Doch ganz ehrlich,
wie gut hat das bisher für dich funktioniert?
Wenn du deine Ziele nicht verfolgst und
schweren Situationen aus dem Weg gehst,
dann spürst du das tief in dir, dass du dich
selbst betrügst. Jedes Mal, wenn du nicht das
tust, was du wirklich tun willst, gibst
du deinem Selbstwertgefühl eine Ohrfeige.
Dieses schmerzhafte Gefühl von Versagen
und Leere kannst du nicht einfach füllen,
indem du beschließt dich selbst zu
lieben oder zu bemitleiden. Und tief
in deinem Inneren weißt du das. Du füllst
es, indem du ins Machen kommst und das tust,
was du wirklich willst. Das ist der
einzige Weg, um dir selbst zu beweisen,
dass du etwas draufhast. Und genau das
lässt dein Selbstwertgefühl sofort steigen.
Erinnere dich einmal an den letzten Erfolg,
den du dir hart erarbeitet hast. Vielleicht
war es ein Sixpack, eine Gehaltserhöhung,
die du rausgehandelt hast oder eine Person,
die du angesprochen hast. Wie hast du dich danach
gefühlt? Stärker? Erfolgreicher? Selbstbewusster?
In der Mythologie gibt es hunderte Geschichten
von Helden, die sich ihren größten Ängsten
stellen und danach transformiert sind. Selbst
jeder Superheldenfilm heutzutage ist darauf
aufgebaut. Spiderman wird vom schüchternen Loser
zum Held, weil er seine Komfortzone verlässt,
trainiert und sich letztendlich seinen
größten Ängsten stellt. Geschichten wie
diese fesseln uns, weil wir uns wünschen
genauso zu sein. Um noch genauer zu sein:
Wir wollen uns genauso fühlen. Wir wollen
vom Loser zum Held werden. Wir wollen unseren
Ängsten ins Gesicht schauen und sie überwinden,
wir wollen den Mut haben unseren eigenen Weg
zu gehen und eine Inspiration für andere
sein. Das Geile ist, dass wir das können.
Carsten, von dem ich dir am Anfang erzählt habe,
ist ein perfektes Beispiel. Er war definitiv kein
Loser, als er bei uns im Coaching gestartet ist,
aber auch er hat seine Heldenreise durchlaufen.
Er hat sich mit jeder Woche im Coaching mehr
und mehr seinen Ängsten gestellt. Bereits nach
kurzer Zeit hatte er den Mut, seine Preise
zu erhöhen, mehr für sich einzustehen und
vieles mehr. Sein erhöhter Selbstwert, hat sich
natürlich auch auf seine Beziehungen ausgewirkt.
Inzwischen ist er glücklicher, verdient mehr
Geld und ist selbstbewusster als je zuvor.
Übrigens haben wir Carsten und allen anderen
unseren Coaching-Klienten, ein Morgenjournal an
die Hand gegeben. Ich habe es dir als kostenlosen
Download in der Beschreibung verlinkt. Das Journal
hilft dir durch gezielte Fragen mentale Stärke
zu gewinnen und dein Selbstvertrauen aufzubauen.
Weg #1 lautet also: Höre auf rumzuheulen und
nach Abkürzungen zu suchen. Höre auf dich
zu bemitleiden. Übrigens bin ich kein Gegner
von Selbstliebe. Ich bin jedoch der Meinung,
dass Selbstliebe alleine nicht reicht, um ein
Mensch zu werden, auf den du stolz sein kannst.
Wenn du mehr Selbstvertrauen willst, dann ziehe
durch, was du dir vornimmst. Egal wie hart es ist.
Das führt uns zu Weg #2.
Wenn du Kampfsport machst oder Profisportler
bist, dann kennst du dieses Prinzip nur zu
gut. Ich mache seit 1,5 Jahren Muay Thai. Wenn
ich nicht zum Training komme, muss ich meinem
Trainer absagen. Klingt nicht besonders
spektakulär, ist aber extrem wichtig. Wir
kommen gleich noch einmal dazu, warum. Außerdem
pusht mein Trainer mich immer wieder an meine
Grenzen. Und oft ist das verdammt unangenehm,
doch genau deshalb habe ich einen Trainer.
Viele Menschen denken, dass die einzige Aufgabe
eines Coaches ist, Wissen zu vermitteln. Das
stimmt jedoch nicht. Dein Coach sollte jemand
sein, der mehr Wissen hat als du UND der dich in
die Pflicht nimmt, deine Ziele zu erreichen. Doch
was hat das mit deinem Selbstwertgefühl zu tun?
Viele Menschen verstecken sich aus Angst davor,
schlecht vor anderen dazustehen. Sie haben
so viele Ziele, die sie erreichen wollen,
aber niemand weiß davon. Und das macht
es viel viel schwerer diese Ziele zu
erreichen. Wir Menschen sind soziale Wesen.
Es treibt uns unglaublich an, jemanden zu
haben, der von unseren Zielen weiß.
Vor allem, wenn es eine Person ist,
zu der wir aufschauen. Wir wollen
diese Person nämlich nicht enttäuschen.
Wenn du zum Beispiel zum Kampfsport gehst,
dann willst du nicht der Einzige im ganzen
Raum sein, der nach 10 Liegestützen
zusammenbricht. Oder noch schlimmer,
derjenige, der gar nicht erst zum Training
kommt. Du willst nicht schlecht vor deinem
Trainer und den anderen Schülern dastehen. Das
treibt dich an, mehr Wiederholungen zu schaffen,
als wenn du allein wärst. Natürlich wäre
es angenehmer in deinem Zimmer zu bleiben
und einfach alle paar Tage mal 10 Liegestütz zu
machen. Dadurch würdest du aber kaum vorankommen.
Wenn du hingegen 3x die Woche eine Stunde zum
Training gehst, wirst du viel schneller Erfolge
erzielen. Es ist zwar unangenehm der Neuling
zu sein, aber dein Wachstum ist viel größer.
Höre deshalb auf dich vor der Welt zu verstecken.
Verpflichte dich gegenüber einer Person,
zu der du aufschaust, zu deinen Zielen. Das ist
im Idealfall ein Coach oder Trainer. Es sollte
jedoch auf keinen Fall ein Mensch sein, der
klein denkt und versucht dich runterzuziehen.
Um dir auch hier wieder von Carstens Entwicklung
zu berichten. Auch Carsten hat es viele Jahre
allein probiert, jedoch mit wenig Erfolg. Im
Coaching hat er direkt am Anfang mit seinem
Coach seine Ziele festgelegt. In regelmäßigen
Calls wurde dann besprochen, ob Carsten seine
Ziele erreicht hat. Bereits kurze Checkup-Calls
können ausreichen, um auf Kurs zu bleiben.
Lass uns zu Punkt 3 kommen, der
mindestens genauso wichtig ist:
#3 Erfolg auf Autopilot
„Deine Gewohnheiten bestimmen deine Zukunft“.
Dieses Zitat von Jack Canfield lässt sich
auch auf dein Selbstwertgefühl anwenden.
Wenn du Selbstwertgefühl aufbauen willst,
dann brauchst du Gewohnheiten, die dir
dabei helfen. Und auf der anderen Seite,
musst du die Gewohnheiten loswerden,
die dein Selbstvertrauen zerstören.
Deine negativen Gewohnheiten loszuwerden,
stoppt die Abwärtsspirale. Positive
Gewohnheiten aufzubauen, führt dazu, dass
du den Aufbau deines Selbstwertgefühls auf
Autopilot stellst. Gewohnheiten sind so
unglaublich mächtig, dass sie wortwörtlich
deine Zukunft bestimmt. Es geht dabei aber nicht
nur um physische Gewohnheiten, die du ausführst.
Also zum Beispiel jeden Tag Sport zu machen.
Es geht genauso um deine Denkgewohnheiten.
Wenn du immer wieder in negative Denkmuster
verfällst, dann wirst du immer wieder Scheitern,
an dir selbst Zweifeln und dich letztendlich
nicht weiterentwickeln. Wenn du hingegen
positive Denkgewohnheiten hast, passiert genau
das Gegenteil. Egal welche Herausforderungen dir
das Leben stellt, du findest immer einen
Weg, um gestärkt daraus hervorzugehen.
Negative Denkgewohnheiten sitzen meist sehr
tief. Auf genau solche Dinge, gehen wir uns
unserem Coaching, der Mental Strength Challenge
individuell ein. Positive Gewohnheiten aufzubauen
kann leichter sein. Deswegen habe ich noch
etwas für dich, bevor wir zum Ende kommen.
Eine kleine Gewohnheit, die wie gesagt,
jeder unserer Klienten und Klientinnen macht,
ist das Morgenjournal zu schreiben.
Das Journal enthält 5 Power Fragen,
die dich mit Motivation, Selbstvertrauen
und Energie in den Tag starten lassen. Das
Journal möchte ich dir schenken,
damit du sofort anfangen kannst,
dein Selbstvertrauen zu steigern. Den Link
dazu findest du unten in der Beschreibung.
Ich will nicht, dass das hier einfach nur
ein weiteres Video ist, das du schaust,
aber dann nichts umsetzt. Deswegen, mache
jetzt den kleinen Step und lade dir das
Journal runter. Und dann auch fleißig die Fragen
beantworten! Dauert nur 5 Minuten pro Tag ;)